hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer I provide
content for you and inspiring software
engineers and today we are recapping the
last 30 days of my job hunt so let's get
into it 30 days ago I set on a mission
to get a job in the same amount of time
it took me to get a job back in 2020 60
days well we are at the halfway mark day
and things are different
things are different than what it was in
2020 and I already knew this but I was
like oh but me I'm a doer I'm a getter I
can and will get everything I want
simply because I demand but no but no I
have been demanding and I am still in
step one still jobless and not in the
middle or end stages of any of the roles
I've applied to so let's recap let's go
over it and talk about what I'm doing
for the next 30 days to really ramp up
these results so in the last 30 days I
have applied to about 160 jobs some
somewhere in between 150 and 160 I'll
put the number right here but yes not a
small amount of jobs for reference back
in 2020 I applied to exactly 66 jobs and
within those 66 jobs I signed on an
offer so now I've applied to about a 100
more jobs than before have gotten less
interviews less offers obviously and I'm
trying to figure out how to move forward
with this so let me break down some
stats so this is the amount of jobs I
have applied to this is the amount of
interviews I have had and this is the
amount of second3 interviews I have had
and finally here's the amount of offers
I've had I've been applying primarily
using LinkedIn however ever there's
about 10ish roles I applied by simply
looking up jobs on Google and going
straight to the company site from there
to apply this is something I did very
religiously back in 2020 but because of
linkedin's stature to me it was fine to
go through Linkedin for applications now
I think for the next 30 days I'm going
to go back with that 2020 approach of
looking up jobs on Google and then going
straight to the job board the thing with
this is it takes a lot more time to do
on LinkedIn it takes me about 6 minutes
to apply to a job to scroll through find
a job I want to apply to hit apply fill
everything out and submit my application
6 minutes is pretty good that's 10 an
hour which doesn't sound great but it
really is and so I'm very curious to see
how much more time goes by by going the
Google approach the first interview I
got was within my first 10 days of
applying to jobs so I was very excited
it was actually Within in my first 10
applications that I even sent out I
believe it was actually number 10 and
they reached out and scheduled a first
round interview with me this process
I've been documenting over the last few
weeks so if you'd like to see a really
stepbystep look into how everything has
been and how I've been handling all of
it I definitely recommend checking out
these videos but yes they reached out
for a first round interview we scheduled
that had it and I was scheduled for the
second round the second round was set to
be a technical which is typically
expected of a tech
job and I studied like crazy I have not
touched data structures and algorithms
in four years since my last job hunt and
even then I did a couple of easy Le code
problems and just prayed for the rest um
I knew now that I am going towards more
midlevel roles these leode eases
especially in the stock market were not
going to cut it so I C
I crammed so hard for 10 days I spent 6
to 10 hours every single day studying
studying dynamic programming
recursion um memorization matrices I
went so ham and now I'm grateful because
I feel like I am so ready for other
technical interviews but it was a very
difficult 10 days because I'm like no I
need to do everything I can to get this
job so show up to the technical and it
is a pretty simple algorithm problem I'm
given it had to do with binary search
and so I given the extensive study I had
done knew exactly how to solve it
however have yall ever seen or heard the
whole problem of like you can throw a
hail mer pass down the field and get a
touchdown but you can't do like a just a
quick little hand over that is where I
was that that's how it felt like I could
do crazy amount of like Matrix problems
and all of this and and DPS to BPS and
all of it but I
couldn't I was making the stupidest
mistake within this W Loop because I was
given such a simple problem and so all
to say I did not get that job and you
know it's fine I can laugh about it but
yes that is how that first job process
went now I mentioned I had two
interviews the second interview I had is
that story is short and sweet they
reached out to me saying hey we want to
talk to you we want to have a phone call
the literal um message they sent me was
phone call interview I was like perfect
need schedu the time now is the time of
the interview I'm waiting waiting
waiting for a phone call and I am not
getting the call after five minutes I
sent the interviewer an email saying hey
please let me know if this time still
works or if you need to reschedule he
sends me back an email a couple minutes
later and was like I waited on the call
for seven minutes so I ended the call
and that is all he said first of all I'm
like what do you mean you waited on the
call I look look look realized that
within the email again labeled phone
call interview Buried buried buried was
and when I say buried I mean you had to
scroll multiple Scrolls through
forwarded messages and everything there
was a link to a Microsoft teams and I'm
like you called this a phone
call so I respond back saying I suly
apologize for the I don't even know if I
said miscommunication or just yeah
inconvenience I would love to um
reschedule if you would be available
never reach back out again he said no
that's it which honestly is fine cuz I
didn't like his attitude either like
you're the one who called this a phone
call interview and so I'm waiting for a
phone call and then I say Hey where's
the phone call he's like I've been on
the call so like I'm cool I think that
was God protecting me in that moment so
that's the recap now for moving forward
something I really want to see is if my
resume truly is the problem or if we are
just in different times where in 2020
companies really started valuing
diversity in a way they hadn't ever
before and now it's four years later and
we're like actually we're cool because
there's research to show that black and
brown people have been
disproportionately affected in Tech
layoffs and I'm curious to see how that
is panning out in the recruitment
process so I actually made a new resume
with a name that is more paston Lobster
sounding and will not be checking off
the boxes that indicate my ethnicity and
well instead
will opt to say that I am of the white
male race and gender now the goal for
this isn't to trick a company into
hiring me or anything like that it's
more to understand where I'm kind of
going wrong right now in these first 30
days is it that my resume truly needs
true revamping which I truly don't
believe that's the case I really love
what my resume says and how it's
displayed and the stats I have is very
comprehensive in my opinion and so if
that's true why else am I not getting
enough am I like enough call backs for
an interview maybe it is just that the
market is so tough right now so you
really got to be over here to get a job
that is you know beginner level or is
there something truly happening in
regards to how companies view diversity
within their teams right now and so in a
quest to answer that question I will be
conducting this experiment and applying
to the same roles that I've been
applying to but with this new resume and
see which one if either are hit and also
applying directly from the company site
after looking up jobs on Google another
thing I'm going to be doing is focusing
on these two specific Tech Industries
gvtech and cryptocurrency let's start
with govtech gvtech I've been hearing
over and over and over again is a lot
more secure than all the other Tech
Industries and also that they have not
slowed down hiring there are also a
number of roles within govtech that are
willing to sponsor you for your security
clearance you don't need to have it
upfront so if that is okay with you and
you're fine with not having an insanely
lavish Tech job gov Tech still pays it's
secure and it's still hiring so why not
go for it so that's one the second one
is cryptocurrency I love keeping up with
tech news and Trends via podcast a
really good one is hard Fork brought to
you by the New York Times and they did a
whole Deep dive on how much
cryptocurrency is playing a role into
this political landscape now hold on
we're not about to talk politics however
what we are going to do is realize that
cryptocurrency is choosing to back up a
candidate and put money to a candidate
based on their ability to assist them in
the legislative fight going on with
crypto assets I'm not going to go too
deep on it but basically because of the
new technology surrounding crypto and
its ability to make people very rich
very quickly and things like that
there are just discussions about how to
handle them when discussing trading and
the way these politicians and people in
financial power choose to handle that
could make or break the crypto industry
so cryptocurrency companies right now
are putting a lot of money towards a
candidate who can almost kind of Promise
them a happy ending oh that
sounds you know what I mean um yes a a
good a good outcome now this is where
job hunting comes in if they succeed
they now have the ability to bring
crypto to the masses like no time before
and they need developers to make that
dream a reality not only developers cuz
here's the thing I'm saying this and I
bet most of you are hearing me and
you're thinking o it's going to be like
really Tech heavy stuff or really crazy
intricate Tech and skills needed for
these roles and I maybe I don't have
that so whatever no if you are a
front-end developer or a mobile
developer you it is my prediction you
are going to be looked at so heavy if
you are applying for crypto rules and it
is because cryptocurrency is such a
fantasy and something that is so hard
for many people to grasp that in order
for these companies to get this product
into the hands of the masses they need a
front-end developer and they need a
mobile developer to fulfill that dream
because it's these two types of
developers that can make their product
very digestible for a large amount of
people for the masses the more complex a
product is the more money needs to be
put in towards developers who can make
it simple and digestible again front-end
developers and mobile developers so
because of this I'm going to be focusing
so heavily these next 30 days on those
two industries I'm going to still be a
applying to the companies we all know
and love and also startups and things
like that however I'm going to be really
focusing on these two in a way that I
just didn't in the first 30 days if
you'd like me to go deeper on the best
companies and industries to be applying
to right now in Tech please let me know
in the comments below so that is my
recap I am very curious to hear what
progress or insights y'all have gathered
in the last 30 days or at the very least
while watching me go through my journey
but I really appreciate the
encouragement I read all y'all's
comments um and it really does motivate
me that much more so thank you so much
for watching and I'll talk to youall
very very soon bye